[Music]
Donald Trump is not a fool he's been a
friend of mine for 25 years I call him a
friend I don't agree with him on many of
his issues
we're 180 degrees apart but Donald Trump
is not a dumb man
you don't acquire the wealth and the
power in the private sector that Donald
Trump has by being stupid
no Donald Trump he does things for a
reason and you can bet when he does
things there's a reason behind it but to
to insinuate or to think he's stupid
you know you will lose to him then
because if you if you go in with that
attitude he'll beat you he saw what they
did to the Reform Party he was with us
back in the Reform Party back in the 90s
when Pat Buchanan came in with his
legions of people took over our party
got the nomination and then didn't even
run he took the money and retired his
previous campaign debts and destroyed
the Reform Party Trump was there then he
saw it well he's doing the same thing to
the Republicans that they did to us he's
in the middle of their run they don't
know what to do with him
and he's leading back in the eighties
the icon of the modern-day Republican
Party was President Ronald Reagan right
it seems to me Ronald Reagan's one of
his most most famous quotes was mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall
I would have to say Ronald Reagan today
he's turning over in his grave over the
thought that the Republicans want to
build a wall between Mexico and the
United States well if they're going to
do that
they shouldn't be racist they should
build one on the Canadian border too
because after all the hijackers of 9/11
came from Canada they didn't come from
Mexico they came via Canada and so the
whole thing's ridiculous do we want to
live in East Berlin no and
Ronald Reagan would not support the
sazabi fact Ronald Reagan probably
wouldn't even be a candidate in the
Republican Party today
[Music]